we're heading to the front line near
Mach more south of muscle it's
blistering hot outside and inside our
armored vehicle the air is unbearable
every couple of kilometers we come to
another military post some manned by
Iraqi soldiers sometimes Kurdish
Peshmerga it was the Peshmerga that
pushed so-called Islamic state out of
Mach more beyond this point our
villagers still firmly under is control
the Iraqi army is trying to liberate
this area one village at a time
eventually they hope to reach muscle but
progress is slow despite support from
the Peshmerga and US airstrikes
lieutenant colonel artem bonanni and his
Peshmerga troops have to be ready for
anything
yes between us and Isis is 5 or 6
kilometers but some time some area
between the Iraqi army and are there and
the ISIS is 1 kilo want you to have some
time to chill doors just the troops here
spend most of their time waiting the is
fighters are mostly active at night and
early morning lieutenant colonel banana
says the jihadists know well that the
anti is operation has its command center
just behind the front line is suicide
bombers have attacked our camp four or
five times in vehicles packed with
explosives of course they are targeting
our headquarters and want to weaken our
soldiers morale this sector is very
important strategically to is edge or
off outside the command center an
armored vehicle patrol in the area
breaks down Peshmerga troops complain
about a lack of modern equipment
despite weapons deliveries from the West
so no ok
along them the soldiers are able to get
the vehicle running again for the time
being we head back to the command center
the commanding officers here stress that
the Peshmerga forces Iraqi army and the
Americans are all working together to
defeat is but Colonel mala Mahdi however
hints that he is unhappy with the Iraqi
army strategy is a large city to take it
we need a well-prepared army and the
Kurdish regional government agree on a
plan then the Peshmerga will take part
in the operation but without the
Peshmerga forces there's no way the
Iraqi army will be successful the Iraqi
generals say they need six times the
troops they have at the moment they also
want more US airstrikes for the Kurds
everything is just taking too long
capturing muscle is a key objective for
the us-led coalition and Iraqi forces
the schmira commanders here however are
skeptical they criticize that the Iraqi
army does not have a plan to liberate
muscle at the checkpoints surrounding
the command center troops remain on
alert they know in this region is has
been weakened but has not yet been
beaten and despite their differences
here everyone agrees retaking morsel is
a daunting task